Reality Bites refrigerated trucks
outside a Manhattan hospital to store
bodies because the morgue is full under
the gaze of the Empire State Building on
the street signs that people realize
it's serious
New Yorkers now wear masks and gloves in
public soldiers are deployed to help
extraordinary times and even aid from
unusual places
I love that expression you go to war
with what you have not what you need
right we're not at the apex so we're
still in the stage where we have the
luxury if you will of gathering as much
as we can so the 1,000 ventilators and
was from China and the 140 from Oregon
and was still shopping the rest of the
United States is watching New Orleans
has opened a medical support facility in
a convention center to ease the strain
on local hospitals
it'll take kovat patients too sick to be
at home but who don't need intensive
care right now as is being accurately
reported in New Orleans that region all
these Jefferson parishes that's the
biggest hot spot that's where we're most
likely to exceed our capacity to deliver
healthcare the soonest and and so that's
where we're working the pandemic is not
only spreading fear it's also awakening
gratitude for those risking their health
for others
[Applause]
give us hope I'm now joined by DWS Pablo
Foley Elias Pablo you've had experience
covering this in administration having
only just arrived from being our
correspondent in Washington President
Trump has said that there going to be a
lot of deaths what do you make of that
strategy well it's you know if you
follow a president from quite closely
it's often quite hard to follow him
because his strategy is at times very
difficult to follow
you know and with particularly with this
situation here we've seen him contradict
himself often he's gone against what
actually the health officials have been
saying and often in these long press
conferences that is being holding there
have it's been at times very confusing
for the American public to really see
what the strategy is I think before we
get into any greater detail that we
should really listen to what President
Trump had to say in his last appearance
in front of the American public so let's
take a look sure this will be probably
the toughest week between this week and
next week and there'll be a lot of death
unfortunately but a lot less depth death
than if this wasn't done but there will
be death we're looking for an obvious
focus and the hardest hit regions some
of them are obvious and some aren't so
obvious they spring up they come and
they they hit you like you got hit by a
club I mean you know it's it's very
strong what he's saying there you know
he's warning Americans that you know
there are gonna be a lot of deaths that
what they should expect this in the
coming days and weeks and but also one
thing that's quite interesting from
President Trump is that the economy
which is very important for President
Trump and let's not forget has been sort
of always present in when he's been
speaking to the public and he sort of
even said in the press conference that
he wants Americans essentially to get
back to work as soon as possible but of
course we know that this is not going to
end in the next few days or weeks
and that's also a message that's being
sent out to people it's confusing as
well and he's saying to people as well
to use a malaria drug which you know his
health officials have been saying hang
on this is all anecdotal let's not be
using this also he's been saying he's
not going to use a mask himself even
though saying
that it is actually something that's you
know good for people to use so very
confusing very hard to follow really
what the strategy is in the meantime of
course in the United States is a lot of
talk about there not being some sort of
federal guideline about how to approach
this coronavirus the the the federal
government leaving it up to the States
how are Trump's actions his behavior
during this affecting the strategy of
individual states well like I was saying
it's very hard to follow the strategy
and it's you know if you look at some
states which are in particularly in the
southern states Republican states will
say I'm just gonna name a few of them
Alabama Arkansas Mississippi three
states which you know our relatives are
very poor compared to other states such
as New York and Washington state in
California New York obviously has huge
numbers of infections and you know these
are areas which are being very lacks
about this and and you know there's been
a lot of criticism saying why are you
taking this approach they haven't really
have forced people to make take any
serious measures and could it be because
of President Trump and the messages that
have been sent out got it publically
alias in our studio with us thank you so
much